Hello, George.
Hey, how are you doing?
I'm doing fine today.
I'm talking to George Trombley
and he's a very interesting
man, he's into Asian languages.
And I think the first one
he learned was Japanese.
And today I want to talk about
how to learn Japanese with George.
Remember if, uh, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, uh, click
on the bell for notifications.
Uh, if you follow me on Spotify
or Apple Podcasts or any
other podcast leave a review.
George.
George live Las Vegas, where we go
to make money on the slot machines,
but George speaks Japanese,
Korean, and other languages.
I would like to, first of all, ask
George ho what do you think what
is the best way to learn Japanese?
It's a big
question.
Uh, but I think the first question that
I always think about when I think if
someone wants to learn a language, I
think, are they interested in the country?
You know, are they
interested in the culture?
Is there something that fascinates them
about it that would keep driving them?
Because as you know, learning
a language isn't just something
you go, oh, I'm going to learn a
language and a month later you have.
There's a lot of, a lot of
effort that has to go into it.
I think.
Um, so if, if for example, you like J pop
music, you watch, you listen to music.
If you like, uh, some sort of drama
in Japanese or some sort of game
that's Japanese that you could get
your hands on the Japanese version.
I think a good thing to do
is kind of follow your heart.
Um, but if you're talking about,
of course, if you're talking,
obviously I teach Japanese, right?
So I'm speaking in
general terms right now.
Right.
But let's say you decide,
okay, I want to learn Japanese.
So in my, in my way of learning,
I did the same thing with Korean.
Uh, I was in a classroom in Japan
and I went to classes in Korea
actually, but you don't have to do
that nowadays because the internet.
So much, uh, access to Korean teachers
or Japanese teachers that, you know,
I would say, hey, get a Japanese
teacher, find a channel on YouTube.
Find some tools that are,
like LingQ, for example.
Find some, tools that will help you learn
and just bust through the basic grammar.
I really believe you should go through
the basic grammar as fast as you
can and learn the writing system.
That would be the step one.
I would say a couple of things.
First of all you have learned Japanese to
a high degree of proficiency and Korean.
What was your motivation?
You said get motivated by something.
So what motivated you to learn.
Well, Japanese was, I mean, it's
the same for Japanese and Korean
for me, but, you know, uh, the start
of Japanese was, I was 12 and my
father was a military contractor.
His company had a contract
with the military and that led
us to be up in Japan in 1985.
So I was 12.
I was in sixth grade on
the military air base.
And one of the classes that I was
required to take was Japanese.
So that got me started.
And I think, uh, it wasn't until maybe
about the next year after that, when
I started thinking about girls and
Japanese girls to me were attractive.
So I just was motivated by that initially.
And then the continued motivation for
me was, uh, I started listening to
J-pop, like I said, and of course I
had access to a lot of fun Japanese TV
every week I was watching the Japanese
top 10 to see the artists that I love.
I learned the lyrics of the music.
I joined the fan club.
I went to the concerts.
I did all of that.
I was a weeb.
I don't know if you know that term
before, weebs were probably a thing.
I just really loved
everything at the time.
Now let's suppose that you're not 12
or 15, and you're not chasing Japanese
girls and you're not into J-pop.
Let's say that you're 30 or 25,
obviously something has to motivate
you so it could be anime, it
could be any number of things.
Well, how about the learning methodology?
You know, my experience
has been that the grammar.
If you just get it up front, it's very
difficult to relate it to anything until
you have enough exposure to the language.
I absolutely agree.
Right.
So this is the problem.
I think, um, that I see a lot of
people, not with grammar per se.
I see a lot of people when they start
learning Japanese, they immediately want
to jump into learning Kanji, for example,
And it's easy to start learning kanji
and then have that as your badge, right?
Like I know 400 Kanji.
I now know 500 Kanji, but in the end you
don't know really how to use that Kanji.
You just, you're, it's, I always
like to call it a parlor trick.
It's something you can brag about.
And I think even a lot of times classes
or a teacher, sometimes if they get a
student that goes that direction, they
let them go that direction because
it's an easy way to grade them to say,
Hey, oh, look, my student made this
progress, but really that's a mistake.
I believe that you, you know, like you
said, you can learn, you could learn,
you can get up to JLPT level in grammar,
the Japanese language proficiency
test level one, and maybe not even
know how to have great conversations.
So what I always think is you learn
grammar, you learn a grammar point, and
then you try to find a way to use it.
If you don't use it,
you're going to lose it.
And you don't want to learn above
what you are capable of doing,
this is what I always believe.
Like, uh, when, for example, when I was
learning Korean, uh, I would, I went to
Korea and I took a group class in the
morning and I took a private class, uh,
after that, or sometimes I flipped it.
Uh, and then whatever I learned that
day, I would kind of keep in my head
and that night I would go out to...
what they have, they have these
language meetups that you can do
in Korea where people get together.
They're learning English and
Korean and Japanese and German.
It's actually really fascinating.
And I would go to those and I would
just, in my mind, I would think
I'm going to use this grammar.
The minute you use the grammar, you,
you build this a bigger connection in
your brain and it becomes more natural.
Now, you know, I don't recommend that
when you're doing something like that.
If you learn a new grammar, never
preface it, don't say, Hey, uh, can
I test this new grammar with you?
Because then that the, the, the native
speaker is going to be on the outlook.
What I like to do is use the grammar,
see what happens sometimes, sometimes,
especially in Korean, I got, you
know, I would learn a grammar, not
fully understand the implication of
that grammar and get a huge laugh.
And now I don't know exactly
why it's funny, but now I know.
Okay.
There's something about
that that makes it funny.
So the next time I do it again, and
I start building an understanding
of why people are laughing
at that particular grammar.
Right.
Um, but without that experience, yeah,
you, you could blindly say things that are
rude, for example, uh, I'm still gonna,
I'm just going to barrel through one more.
Uh, my, uh, video editor might.
He's learning Japanese.
And he was saying a complicated
sentence to me the other day.
And he used "nante" in
Japanese in a really weird way.
And it sounded like he said something
like, uh, ... which, which could mean,
you know, oh man, I can't believe
you can actually make delicious
cooking, but he wasn't trying to
say that he didn't understand the
implications of what "nante" does.
So without using that grammar, You know,
no, the first time he uses it, he might've
made that mistake, but he would have
learned right away that wasn't good to do.
So using it absolutely right
away as the best thing to do.
Don't use words that
you're not going to use.
Don't learn Kanji, you know, I'm a
big fan of just-in-time learning after
you get the basics down just, just
in time learning for those things.
Right.
Interesting.
I mean, everyone has a different approach.
In my case, I had learned
Chinese beforehand.
So I had that.
Uh, so that was not an issue.
I tend to favor as you know, a lot more
input before I speak, unless I'm there,
like in your situation, you were in
Japan, you were in Korea, you have all
kinds of opportunity to use the language.
I guess one of the messages there is that
there's many different roads that are
going to take us to success in, in life.
Uh, and it depends on your circumstance,
but, uh, so you, you were totally into
Japanese learning and then all of a
sudden you got interested in Korean.
Why did you get interested in Korean?
Could I go back just a second
though, and talk about the input.
So yeah, the input is
something I highly recommend.
Um, one of the things that, so I have the
video series on YouTube and one thing I
constantly recommend to people is, is for
them to listen to Japanese radio, right.
Uh, find a good podcast or a
radio, but it can't be one...
I firmly believe it shouldn't be one
that's designed for students of Japanese
or designed for students in Korean.
I want full-blown, full-speed, fully
actuated Korean or Japanese so that
your brain can hear things, um, that,
that you're not going to hear in a
classroom because it's in a sense when
you're learning in a classroom it's fun
and all, but it's classroom Japanese.
It's, it's a subset of Japanese.
And you know, even me, you know,
before I went to Korea, I learned
in a, with a meetup group here.
So I had learned those kind of,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Like really clean sentences that have
no advanced grammar because it's a lower
level sentence, and it's not said in a
way with any "ums" or "ahs", you know?
But then you go to Korea and, or
you go to Japan and all of a sudden
you're in a convenience store and
they say something super basic back
to you, but you've never heard it.
You've never been exposed to it.
But if you had been watching dramas
or listening to people speak, your
brain would have picked up things.
I did it with Chinese too.
The thing is, um, you know, podcasts.
Now you mentioned something
I've had trouble finding good
podcasts in Korean and Japanese.
Oh.
Uh...
I can recommend some.
Yeah.
I think our listeners would be very
interested in getting lists of good...
I can give you two right
now, if you'd like.
Sure.
Well, uh, yeah, I'll put
them in the description box.
Okay, tell me what they are.
And I'll say it in a way
that it's easy to find.
So one is a super casual one.
If you look up, uh, the, the full
Japanese name is something like...
but if you look up J U R I.
JURI
And she also has a YouTube channel.
She's a fairly minor one, but the topics
that she talks about are very interesting.
It's about, it's people that want
to get married and they're, they're,
they're asking dating questions to her.
So she will receive a question
from a, from a guy and then she'll
read the question, then answer it.
But she's speaking clearly and
on an interesting lower level
topic about relationships, right?
So that's super, that's short.
And as you say, those kinds
of things have resonance.
Whereas what you've got in the
classroom has no residence.
The narrator is bored.
The content is uninteresting.
Whereas, so J U R I.
Okay.
That's what...
yeah, JURI.
And the second one that I love for the
quality of sound and the fact that it's
really high level, but yet they're still
speaking in a normal speaking tone.
It's cozy up, C O Z Y up the full
name of the show is something like.
Something news, kozy up in katakana.
Uh, but, but that one is excellent
because they open up with a news item.
Right.
And it's like, very, it's like NHK.
This is the day...
they say the news very kind of formal
and then they go, okay, we're here today
with commentator so-and-so and then they
go back and forth and talk about it.
So once you're, once, now this is
something I even recommend if you're
new, new, new, it's fine because they're
speaking in very normal terms, right.
Just every now and then you're
gonna hear things that are super
high level, but guess what?
It doesn't matter what you
listen to in the beginning.
You're not gonna understand
any of it anyway.
J U R I, Juri is one and the
other one is cozy up: C O Z Y.
Or zed depending on...
They also have a YouTube channel,
so you can get it on like a
podcast app or YouTube channel.
Uh, those are two for that...
Do either of them have transcripts?
Not that I know of.
Not that you know of.
Okay.
I know that that's important.
I know it's important for LingQ, right?
You can throw these onto a happy
scribe, automatic transcription
service and it's kind of 90%.
Okay.
All right.
That's very good.
The thing about these things?
Sorry, go ahead.
No, I was going to say to you, I
have some good podcasts for Korean.
I have an excellent one for Korean.
It's called...
now you're not going to
find that one in English.
It means two o'clock date.
And it's, I think one of the longest
running, uh, Korean radio shows
in all of Korea, uh, I listened to
it all the time and every year or
so they'll change the announcer.
I, it, my opinion firmly is that
the last announcer was the best,
but, uh, now it's two people that...
Somehow we're going to find these, I'm
going to put them in the description.
I'm going to link, I'll,
I'll send you the links.
Let me see if there's anything, uh,
let me see, let me just see quickly
if I can easily give you something
that identifies that one easier.
Uh, but yeah, that one, that one's
good because it's two people talking
and they go rapid fire through topics.
And then what they'll do is they'll
introduce something that like a
housewife in Busan had a problem,
and then she, they, so the topics
change fresh enough, right?
So that if your Korean is at an
intermediate level, there might
be one particular thing where all
of a sudden you understand, right?
And then the next topic will come
and you might not understand.
So I call that like this random
pocket of understanding and I, my
Korean significantly improved just
listening to that for 30 or 40
minutes, like as I was driving around.
Uh, and once you get good, you start
being like, you start thinking,
oh, well, I'm actually enjoying the
content you stop thinking about,
oh, I'm, I'm speaking Korean.
But what I get, what I get from you.
And I think the big lesson is, is
your enthusiasm, your willingness
to not understand your willingness
to be in a situation where you can't
quite say what you want to say.
You don't quite understand
everything that's being said, and
you're happy, nevertheless, and
you just throw yourself into it.
And in that, you know, that approach
is actually better than sitting in a
classroom, trying to nail everything down,
wanting to understand everything and never
getting beyond that class, you will learn.
You learn so many things that the
teacher would never think to teach
you by listening to people talk.
And I, if you want them, uh,
Steve, I've got, I've got on here.
So what I do is I get the podcast
and then I put like a, I rename
it so that it goes in order.
I renamed my like J uh, close
parentheses, K close parentheses.
I have Vietnamese.
Uh, I have Russian, whatever
I was learning for the moment.
Uh, I would get it.
I have two or three good German
ones, so I can, I can give you a
good Chinese one if you want one too.
How many languages are you working on?
Well, I'm striving to be
the next Steve Kaufmann.
Um...
You've got a few more years
to go though, so that's good.
No, you really inspired me because
when I heard you were 75 and you got 20
languages, I thought, well, I'm 48, right?
I've got Japanese, Korean.
I'm fairly happy with my Chinese.
Although I do need more work.
I started German.
Uh, and then once, um, What's his name?
Oh my gosh.
I shouldn't forget this
Laoshu50500, when he passed away.
Right.
Uh, I had, I had, uh, I had only a
brief interaction with him and it wasn't
a positive one, unfortunately, but
when he passed away, I went up to his
channel and I watched more of his stuff.
I found out how young he was and
I saw on his Facebook, he's doing
these really weird languages that
I would never think to learn.
Right.
And then I thought that guy had,
he had inspired so many people.
I thought, what am I doing?
I'm just sitting here not
learning more languages.
So that day I booked Tagalog,
which I've really loved.
Tagalog is amazing.
And, uh, and Vietnamese.
So...
I mean, Laushu was amazing, very
humble guy interested in, you
know, it didn't Hmong, uh, you
know, no Georgian, you name it.
The guy was, and he had such a breadth
of interests in terms of languages.
And another guy who was doing
that is Richard Simcott.
I just saw him speaking, uh, Estonian and,
and people, I think, you know, we don't
have to be perfect in these languages.
It's, it's such a delight to discover a
new language, to explore a new language.
Uh, so good for you.
Absolutely good for you.
It really is.
You know, th there's, there's a, there's
a subset in the Japanese community.
I haven't seen it in the Korean community
yet where they're striving for perfection
or they, they put a lot of emphasis
on the Japanese learning community
in the Japanese learning community.
Um, It's never been my thing.
You know, I saw a TED talk once and it,
it really summed up everything I've ever
believed about learning a language is that
language is a tool, not an art to master.
And it's a tool for communicating.
It's also a tool for discovering more
about different cultures, different
countries and stuff like that.
It's not, it's not a, it's not
synchronized diving at the Olympic games.
Right.
We don't have to achieve perfection.
If that's what people want
to do, that's fine too.
Yeah.
Well, that's the thing that it really
is, especially nowadays, if you want
to strive for perfection, you can, but
my question is what's your goal, right?
Is that your goal or goal is
to make friends in the country?
Always a hundred percent.
So my goal in a new language is to
get two friends that don't speak
English so that there's no influence
of the western mind on them.
But one more thing though, is this
by learning, say Tagalog or Korean or
whatever, you're learning, you have a
different perception of those people.
Like those people come alive.
All of a sudden, that's just not
a place on the globe or a map.
Those are real people.
Now you have a bit of a sense,
not maybe very deep yet, but a
bit of a sense of those people.
That's much more alive than
when you have never even spoken
or understood any of them.
Well, if I can add to that
and say something slightly
controversial, if you're living in
America, that's where I live now.
So I see this, you know, we don't
really understand foreigners because
we're America and we're number
one and everyone speaks English.
Right, right.
So we're used to non native speaking
English and maybe not a perfect way.
Right.
So then maybe we think, oh, they're not so
smart, but the minute you start speaking
in their language, you go, you realize
they are really smart, just like we are.
And it's a controversial thing
because that's a weird thing to
say, but I'll give you an example.
I made a friend in Korea through
Hello Talk, which is an amazing
app that I absolutely love.
And, uh, when I first met her, I
just thought she was kinda dumb.
Like just not super intelligent, but
it was my Korean level that needed
to increase because once I spoke more
Korean, I found out she was deep-thinking,
you know, she had deep thought.
She was just a quiet person.
You know, I...
This is the problem.
This is why people are intimidated.
Uh, about speaking another language
because they consider themselves
intelligent in their own language.
Doesn't matter who you are,
American, Chinese, whatever.
And you realize that when you're
speaking this foreign language,
all of a sudden you're lessened.
So most adults don't like that.
Like kids don't care, kids just
want to, you know, play with their
friends, but an adult thinks, well,
you know, I'm an educated person
in my language, whatever it may be.
And now I'm going to speak this other
language and all of a sudden I'm less,
or at least come across as less educated.
That never bothered me but there
are people who are bothered by that.
And I think we have to
get beyond that and.
Just strive to communicate and,
and not worry about how, you
know, whatever imperfections there
are and how we use the language.
I mean, we all like to improve.
That's fine.
It's extremely frustrating when you're
learning a new language, because you
know how to say things in English.
And even for me, you know, I already
knew how to say things in Japanese.
Now I can't say them in Korean
or I can't say them in Chinese.
So you get very frustrated.
And this is a common thing that
I see over these 20 plus years of
teaching Japanese and now Korean.
So I give this advice all the time.
I say, say what you can say,
not what you want to say.
I don't find it frustrating when I kind
of say things because I then reflect
back on where I was six months ago.
Well, you're also a veteran, you're
a veteran, uh, language learner.
So you're aware and I'm aware of that too.
So I say look at me all of a sudden I
can say things in Persian or Arabic.
I can't quite nail it
the way I would like to.
Uh, I keep on forgetting
things that I know.
I know these words and I can't find them
when I'm speaking, but so what, you know,
look at me now versus six months earlier.
So we have to give ourselves
credit for what we've done.
Yeah, you, you have to
recognize where you are.
And I think, you know, we're like
that frog in a boiling pot that
we don't realize how hot it got.
Right.
But in a better way, we don't
know how good we've got until we
compare ourselves to someone else
or we start another language.
But why don't we end it here?
Okay.
And, uh, the main thing that you
exude is enthusiasm, plus a lot
of experience in learning these
languages and helping others learn.
So thank you very much
for the conversation.
All right.
Hey, thanks.
See you next time.
Okay.
Have a good day, Steve.
Thank you.
Bye bye.